Roger gave this amazing little monologue where he said, hey, he said he's sick and tired of all these engineers complaining about people leaving. And they had to understand that Apple gets thousands of resumes every single day. And he said, if you want to see the impact you're going to leave leaving the company, he said, put your hand in a bucket of water and pull it back out and look at the hole you left. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 40 recorded on July 28th, 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Sean Parent, and he tells us the story of the battle between Project Star Trek and PowerPC. So a little background here. At Apple, when I joined Apple, I was working on QuickTry GX, and then I switched to a team which was known as the Blue Meanies, which were, the purpose of the Blue Meanies is they were the system integration architects. This was around Mac OS System 7, during Mac OS System 7 development.
罗杰曾发表过一段精彩绝伦的独白，他说，嘿，他说他厌倦了所有这些工程师抱怨人员离职。他们必须明白，苹果每天都会收到成千上万份简历。他说，如果你想看看你离开公司会留下什么影响，他说，把你的手伸进一桶水里，然后再抽出来，看看你留下的那个洞。欢迎收看第40集ADSP播客，本期节目于2021年7月28日录制。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起采访了肖恩·帕伦特，他给我们讲了星际迷航项目与PowerPC之间对抗的故事。所以这里有些背景。在苹果，当我加入苹果时，我从事的是QuickTime GX项目，然后我转到一个被称为“蓝色怪人”（Blue Meanies）的团队，他们的目的是，蓝色怪人是系统集成架构师。这大约是在Mac OS System 7时期，在Mac OS System 7开发期间。
So the Blue Meanies basically went around and figured out what all the various teams at Adobe were doing and tried to find areas where teams should be talking together more and coordinating more and just kind of making connections there. And they would also help with, you know, difficult to solve engineering problems that came about in kind of integrating components. Is this like meanies as in like M-E-A-n-i-e-s like someone who is mean to someone yeah you know the references to the uh the the the the blue meanies in the uh uh beatles uh uh what is it yellow submarine movie so oh okay so it's a it's a cultural reference that i'm out of the loop on yeah so so just search blue meanies and you'll see a little cartoon figure of what a blue meanie looks
所以蓝色怪人基本上四处奔走，弄清楚Adobe的所有各个团队都在做什么，并试图找到团队应该更多地交流和协调的领域，并在那里建立联系。他们还会协助解决在组件集成过程中出现的、难以解决的工程问题。这就像是“meanies”那种“M-E-A-N-I-E-S”，也就是刻薄的人吗？对，你知道这指的是甲壳虫乐队的《黄色潜水艇》电影里的那个“蓝色怪人”吧？哦，好吧，这是一个我没跟上时代潮流的文化梗。对，所以只要搜一下蓝色怪人，你就会看到一个长得像蓝色怪人的小卡通形象。
like do you know what this is bryce uh no i think we are uh i think we're wrong generation for us to understand this connor yeah i do know who the beat are okay the disappointments in the back I guess yes that's a good thing yes so yeah so look up what a blue media is and they're cute little cartoon characters but you know Apple at the time was divided into pink and blue where pink eventually spun off to be Taligent. It was kind of future macOS thing, which never shipped. It ended up in a partnership with IBM as a company called Taligent. And blue was kind of traditional macOS.
你知道这是什么吗，布莱斯？不，我觉得我们，我觉得我们的年代不对，理解不了这个，康纳。不，我确实知道甲壳虫乐队是谁，好吧。我想，后面那些让人失望的家伙们是的，这是一件好事，对。所以，去查查看什么是蓝色怪人，它们是可爱的卡通角色，但你知道当时的苹果分为粉色和蓝色，粉色后来分拆成了Taligent。这有点像未来的macOS项目，但从未发布。它最终以Taligent公司的名义与IBM建立了合作关系。而蓝色则有点像是传统的macOS。
And so the blue meanies, that's where the blue comes in. And so, yeah, so I was working on BlueMeanies and then part of what I was doing on BlueMeanies was I got tasked to start tracking a couple of projects that were shaping up the context here was Macs were sitting on Motorola 68000000 processors, and Intel had the first Pentiums coming soon. And even though the first Pentiums were a flaming hot, massive energy-cons consuming device, they were faster than anything that Motorola had in their pipeline in the 68k line. And Motorola was struggling with process manufacturing to build faster 68k'ss to kind of move to standard, to smaller manufacturing processes.
所以蓝色怪人，这就是“蓝色”的由来。所以，是的，我当时在做蓝色怪人，然后我在蓝色怪人的一部分工作是，我被派去开始追踪几个正在成型的项目，当时的背景是Mac使用的是摩托罗拉68000处理器，而英特尔的首批奔腾处理器即将推出。尽管最初的奔腾处理器是一个发热量巨大、耗电巨大的设备，但它们比摩托罗拉68k产品线中正在研发的任何东西都要快。而摩托罗拉在制造工艺上举步维艰，无法制造出更快的68k芯片来转向标准、更小的制造工艺。
And so the answer seemed to be either to switch to switch max to Intel or switch max to risk architecture. And so somebody at Apple, a guy named Gary Davidian, wrote an emulator for the 88110, which was Motorola's risk processor. And he wrote a 68K emulator and showed that he was able to run Macintosh in kind of a fully emulated environment on a 88 110 with reasonable performance right right it it
所以当时的解决方案似乎要么是将Mac切换到英特尔，要么是切换到RISC架构。因此，苹果的一位名叫加里·达维迪安（Gary Davidian）的员工，为摩托罗拉的RISC处理器88110编写了一个模拟器。他编写了一个68K模拟器，并展示了能够在88110上以合理的性能在完全模拟的环境中运行麦金塔电脑。没错，确实是这样。
wasn't it wasn't fast but but it didn't didn't suck and Apple established a partnership with Novell, which was a non-Microsoft company that had a competitor to DOS at the time. But, you know, Windows was kind of fairly new at this point. Novell didn't have an answer to Windows. And so Apple also entered into a partnership with Novell to investigate moving Macintosh onto Intel processors using Novell's underlying kernel.
它虽然不快，但并不糟糕。苹果与Novell建立了一步合作关系，Novell是一家非微软公司，当时拥有一个DOS的竞争对手。但是，你知道的，Windows在当时还比较新。Novell对Windows并没有什么应对之策。因此，苹果也与Novell建立了合作关系，以研究利用Novell的底层内核将麦金塔电脑迁移到英特尔处理器上。
And Apple kind of providing the GUI interface on top of that. And that was known as the Star Trek project. You can look these things up online now. They're fairly well documented. Well, the Star Trek project was this very high-profile partnership inside of Apple. And the team had, like, a tremendous amount of resources, and it was a large team, and they were, you know, this pirate team, you know, semi-super-secret.
苹果则在其之上提供图形用户界面。这就是所谓的星际迷航项目。你们现在可以在网上查到这些东西。它们有相当多的文档记录。嗯，星际迷航项目是苹果内部一个备受瞩目的合作项目。团队拥有大量的资源，这是一个庞大的团队，他们是一群海盗般的团队，半保密的。
They had their own floor of a building and, you know, pool tables and perks and lots of the best engineering talent, several of the Blue Meanies, kind of slid over into the Star Trek project. And I was monitoring the 88110 and the RISC project. And out of that, we created a little group to see if we could run with this idea of having some native code and some emulated code and bring up a machine in that environment using a RISC processor.
他们拥有大楼的一整层楼，有台球桌、福利以及大量最优秀的工程人才，其中有几个蓝色怪人跳槽到了星际迷航项目。而我则在监控88110和RISC项目。由此，我们成立了一个小团队，看看能否推进这样一种想法：即拥有一些本地代码和一些模拟代码，并在该环境中使用RISC处理器启动一台机器。
And so it started as just a bunch of committee meetings exploring it, and eventually we got to the point where things were coming pretty far along, and it was starting to look feasible. of all things. I ended up staying up all night kind of scribbling in a notebook of how mixed mode could actually work across for the seamless integration between 68K and PowerPC code, and neither code had to know about the other, and you could get existing Mac software to run even though everything in an existing 68K Mac was running in supervisory space, so you could have interrupt handlers and all of these things, you know, executing in user applications or system extensions or things of that, how I could make all of that work.
所以它最初只是一堆探讨这个问题的委员会会议，最终我们的进展相当顺利，并且开始显得切实可行。鬼使神差地，我居然熬夜在笔记本上乱涂乱画，研究混合模式如何在68K和PowerPC代码之间实现无缝集成，而双方代码都不需要了解对方，并且你可以让现有的Mac软件运行，尽管现有的68K Mac中的一切都在管理空间中运行，因此你可以有中断处理程序以及所有这些在用户应用程序或系统扩展或类似东西中执行的东西，我将如何让所有这些都能工作。
And, you know, even though I kind of have the aha moment, you know, this was not just me. There were a whole bunch of people who worked on this and were all listed on a patent for mixed mode. And my ideas were just putting together pieces that other people had. So in any case, I go back to Apple and I start like, oh, I got this figured out. This is how it all works and scribble it on the diagram
而且，你知道，尽管我有一种顿悟的时刻，但这不仅仅是我一个人。有一大群人参与了这项工作，他们都名列混合模式的专利上。我的想法只是把别人的拼图拼凑在一起。无论如何，我回到苹果，开始想，哦，我想通了。这就是它的工作原理，并把它乱涂在图表上。
and everybody's like, okay. And from there, we kind of moved out of committees and formed a team, the PowerPC team. And one of the people who we brought in was an individual, Phil Koch, who had been a professor at Dartmouth. And he joined Apple to be engineering manager on this team.
每个人都觉得，好吧。从那时起，我们有点走出了委员会，并组建了一个团队，即PowerPC团队。我们引进的人员之一是菲尔·科赫（Phil Koch），他曾是达特茅斯学院的教授。他加入苹果担任该团队的工程经理。
And we ended up with several first interns and then later hires who had been his students at Dartmouth who kind of came in. But we were a very small team. It was just a handful of us literally working on this. And we had a small cluster of offices mixed up with a bunch of other teams and kind of, you know, no support. It was a secret Skunk Works project, but this was not like Star Trek's project.
我们最终迎来了几位最初的实习生，后来又招聘了曾是他在达特茅斯学院学生的年轻人加入。但我们是一个非常小的团队。真的只有区区几个人在做这个。我们有一小片办公室，和许多其他团队混在一起，而且，可以说，没有任何支持。这是一个秘密的“臭鼬工厂”项目，但这和星际迷航项目不一样。
We were not, like, well-funded. We didn't have perks. We were just kind of struggling along. And eventually, well, Scully came in at one point and said, oh, okay, so I cut this deal with IBM, and we're going with power architecture, so this will be a new processor, PowerPC, and honestly, we had been evaluating RISC chips, and like power architecture was, you know, like not even on the first page of candidates. But to Scully's credit, Scully was like, yeah, I looked at your list.
我们没有获得充足的资金。我们没有福利。我们只是在苦苦挣扎。最后，斯卡利在某个时候进来，说，哦，好吧，我和IBM达成了一笔交易，我们要采用Power架构，所以这将是一个新处理器，PowerPC，老实说，我们当时一直在评估RISC芯片，像Power架构，你知道的，甚至不在候选名单的第一页上。但值得赞赏的是，斯卡利说，是的，我看过你们的名单了。
There aren't that many companies that can produce chips in the volume that we need. And, you know, IBM is one of them. And so it became this very complicated partnership with IBM and with Motorola, which is where PowerPC came from. So there was a three-way partnership around the processor chips. There was an extended partnership with IBM around Taligent, which was Apple's pink operating system, which would maybe be a future operating system running on PowerPC. And there was an effort to bring up Macintosh software on top of AIX, and that actually shipped at some point. AIX is IBM's flavor of Unix. And then there was our project which was secret even to IBM because IBM thought that when they were shipping these things that it would
没有多少公司能够以我们需要的规模生产芯片。而且，你知道，IBM就是其中之一。因此，这就演变成了与IBM以及摩托罗拉的一个非常复杂的合作关系，PowerPC就是这么来的。所以围绕处理器芯片有一个三方合作。围绕Taligent（苹果的粉色操作系统，可能会成为运行在PowerPC上的未来操作系统）与IBM有一个扩展合作。还有一个努力是将麦金塔软件移植到AIX上运行，这在某个时候确实发布了。AIX是IBM版本的Unix。然后是我们的项目，它甚至对IBM来说都是个秘密，因为IBM认为当他们出货这些东西时，
be their AIX kernel sitting underneath Macintoshes that were PowerPC, and Apple wanted a kind of side bet on maybe we could do this just with all Apple software. And so that was the team that I was working on. And so we got to the point where we were, you know, first we prototyped everything. We, like, prototyped all of Mixed Mode running 68K to 68K, which sounds kind of weird, but it actually worked as a proof of concept, and kind of prototyped the architecture, and then started building things on power machines, which are not quite power machines, to get things kind of limping along. And then eventually we had PowerPC silicon and we built boards that you can plug into 68k max Quadrate hundreds and you know went through like how do you you know use logic analyzers to get to the point where you can boot these devices and
这将是他们的AIX内核运行在PowerPC麦金塔电脑的下方，而苹果希望进行一场对冲，也许我们可以仅使用全苹果的软件来完成这一切。这就是我当时所在的团队。所以我们推进到了这样的阶段：首先我们对所有东西进行了原型制作。我们制作了运行68K到68K的所有混合模式的原型，这听起来有点奇怪，但它作为概念验证确实起作用了，并且对架构进行了原型制作，然后开始在功率机器（虽然还不是真正的PowerPC机器）上构建东西，让事情勉强运行起来。后来我们有了PowerPC芯片，我们制造了可以插入68k Mac Quadra几百系列的插槽的板子，并且，你知道，经历了一步步的过程，比如如何使用逻辑分析仪来达到可以启动这些设备的程度，
then we were able to get them up inside of an emulator booting on them based off of Gary Davidian's work, but now ported to PowerPC. And then finally we get to show mixed mode. And the first thing we moved over to mixed mode was there was an old Mac toolbox routine called setRect, which all it did was it took, you know, four coordinates of 16-bit integers, top left, bottom right, and returned a struct of those four integers that were passed as arguments. So an almost do-nothing routine, it's basically just copying four integers from the stack into a struct on the heap, or I'm sorry, into a struct on the stack. So it's just copying four integers. But the interesting thing about set-rect was it got called all over the place. It got called at
然后我们能够在基于加里·达维迪安（Gary Davidian）的工作构建的模拟器内部启动它们，但现在已经移植到了PowerPC上。最后，我们展示了混合模式。我们转移到混合模式的第一件事是一个名为setRect的老式Mac工具箱例程，它的全部作用就是获取四个16位整数的坐标（左上角、右下角），并返回一个由这四个作为参数传递的整数组成的结构体。所以这是一个几乎什么都不做的例程，它基本上只是将堆栈中的四个整数复制到堆上的结构体中，或者，抱歉，是复制到堆栈中的结构体中。所以它只是复制四个整数。但setRect有趣的地方在于它被到处调用。它在
interrupt time, it got called from patches to the operating system, it got, you know, called from signal handlers, it was everywhere. And so we were able to take that routine native and show that, you know, native code could call it, native code could call it even if it had been patched with a 68k code. 68k code could call it regardless of the execution context and it would execute correctly and return correctly and keep the state of the machine and nothing fell apart, right? Everything still worked. And so that was our proof of concept. And after we got that running, the next day, we got it running kind of late in the evening. And the next morning, Phil Koch walked into my office and closed the door and said, I owe you an apology.
中断时被调用，从操作系统的补丁中被调用，它被，你知道的，从信号处理程序中被调用，无处不在。因此，我们能够将该例程原生化，并证明原生代码可以调用它，即使它被68k代码打过补丁，原生代码也可以调用它。68k代码可以调用它，而不管执行上下文如何，它都能正确执行和返回，并保持机器的状态，并且没有崩溃，对吧？一切仍然正常工作。这就是我们的概念验证。在我们让它运行后的第二天，我们在那天傍晚很晚的时候让它运行起来了。第二天早上，菲尔·科赫走进我的办公室，关上门说：“我欠你一个道歉。”
And I said, what for? And he said, this whole Mixmo thing thing I didn't think it was going to work and I said well you should have said something he's like oh no you explained it I would explain it to anybody who wanted to hear
我问：“为什么？”他说：“关于这个混合模式的事情，我原以为它行不通。”我说：“那你早该说啊。”他说：“哦，不，你解释过，我会向任何想听的人解释。”
walk up to the whiteboard and walk through the logic of how it worked through all the transitions he said I saw what you were doing. I couldn't poke a hole in it. He said, just my gut said this isn't going to work. And I said, well, you know, you don't owe me an apology for that, right? Thanks for letting us run it out.
走到白板前，梳理它如何通过所有转换工作的逻辑。他说：“我看到了你在做什么。我挑不出毛病。”他说：“只是我的直觉告诉我这行不通。”我说：“好吧，你知道的，你不需要为那个向我道歉，对吧？谢谢你让我们把它做出来。”
And he said, no, no. He said, you don't understand. My reports to my bosses and the executives have been, this team's doing this, you know, wacky mix mode thing. I don't think it's going to work. He said, so you want to know why this team doesn't have the funding that Star Trek has? Why other teams aren't excited about porting their code to PowerPC, why this team has like zero support, why it's just a handful of people.
他说：“不，不。你不明白，”他说，“我向我的老板和高管们的汇报一直是，这个团队正在做这个，你知道的，疯狂的混合模式的东西。我不认为它会成功。”他说，“所以你想知道为什么这个团队没有像星际迷航那样多的资金吗？为什么其他团队对将他们的代码移植到PowerPC不感兴趣，为什么这个团队几乎零支持，为什么只有区区几个人吗？”
He said, because you're the side bet that I didn't think was going to work. Okay. So, you know, in reality, in retrospect, I think that keeping the team small, keeping the team focused, keeping all the outside distractions from pouring in was critical to actually getting this to ship. I give Scott Boyd, who was technical lead on this project for most of the duration of the project, a lot of credit for getting this thing shipped. And he coined the acronym NNTS, which was not necessary to ship. And kind of any time it was like, oh, I think we should be doing X, he would respond with an email of just NNTS, meaning like good idea, bad idea, I don't care, it's not necessary to ship.
他说：“因为你们就是那个我以为不会成功的对冲押注。”好吧。所以，你知道，实际上，事后看来，保持团队的小规模，保持团队的专注，防止所有外部干扰涌入，对于最终让产品上市至关重要。我非常感谢斯科特·博伊德（Scott Boyd），他在项目的大部分时间里担任该项目的技术主管，他为将这个产品推向市场做出了很大贡献。他创造了缩写NNTS，即“非上市必需品”（not necessary to ship）。每当有人说，“哦，我觉得我们应该做X”，他就会回复一封电子邮件，内容仅仅是“NNTS”，意思是好主意、坏主意，我不在乎，这不是上市必需的。
So very much trying to keep the team focused. So that all happened and we shipped PowerPC and PowerPC launched and it was a big success. And PowerPC was known as V0 internally because there was a plan. Apple had a roadmap that was kind of V1, V2, V3 of what they were going to do with their new kernel work. And PowerPC, we scaled it back so much to get it out the door that we called it V0. And the team pitched a follow-on which was called Alberto, which is VO5, if anybody knows the hair product Alberto VO5. But yeah, so it was a half step between V0 and V1. But management at the time said no, we have to drive towards V1, and so that project
所以极力保持团队的专注。这一切都发生了，我们推出了PowerPC，PowerPC发布并取得了巨大的成功。PowerPC在内部被称为V0，因为有一个计划。苹果有一个路线图，包括V1、V2、V3，关于他们将如何处理新的内核工作。而PowerPC，为了将其推向市场，我们对其进行了大量缩减，以至于我们称之为V0。团队提出了一个后续项目，名为Alberto，如果有人知道Alberto VO5这款美发产品的话，它就是VO5。但是，是的，所以它是V0和V1之间的半步。但当时的管理层说不，我们必须朝着V1推进，所以那个项目
got canceled, and Roger Heinen, who was leading system software at the time, Apple was losing a lot of talent at this time, Apple was kind of bleeding cash and was scrambling, even with PowerPC's success. You know, Apple was looking to enable clones, and this is, like, soon after, kind of this unwinding is when Steve Jobs kind of did the reverse takeover thing and came back to Apple. So Apple had been bleeding talent and there was a meeting with Roger Heinen, who was head of system software, and the engineers were raising the concerns in the audience going,
被取消了，当时领导系统软件的罗杰·海嫩（Roger Heinen），苹果当时正在流失大量人才，苹果的现金正在流血，即使在PowerPC取得成功的情况下，也在艰难挣扎。你知道，苹果在寻求开放克隆机，这大约是，在这个解体后不久，史蒂夫·乔布斯进行了反向收购并回到苹果的时候。所以苹果一直在流失人才，当时与系统软件负责人罗杰·海嫩开了一场会，台下的工程师们提出了担忧，
you know, what are you going to do to keep talent here and keep people from leaving? leaving and Roger gave this amazing little monologue where he said he's sick and tired of all these engineers complaining about people leaving and they had to understand that Apple gets thousands of resumes every single day and he said if you want to see the impact you're going to leave leaving the company, he said, put your hand in a bucket of water and pull it back out and look at the hole you left. You know, basically meaning that like no engineer mattered. And one of the senior colonel engineers like walked up to the front of the little amphitheater we were in and handed Roger his badge and just kept walking. Morale was clearly high. Morale was clearly high.
你知道的，你们要采取什么措施来留住这里的人才，防止人员流失？罗杰发表了一段精彩绝伦的小独白，他说他厌倦了所有这些工程师抱怨人员离职，他们必须明白，苹果每天都会收到成千上万份简历，他说，如果你想看看你离开公司会留下什么影响，他说，把你的手伸进一桶水里，然后再抽出来，看看你留下的那个洞。你知道，这基本上意味着任何工程师都无关紧要。其中一位资深内核工程师走到我们所在的那个小型露天剧场的正面，把他的胸牌交给了罗杰，然后头也不回地走了。士气显然很高。士气显然很高。
We also had, in one of the hallways, we had tombstones, whereas each engineer left, we kind of drew a tombstone and put rip in their name on it so yeah morale was really high um when you said amazing speech i thought it was going to be this like uplifting you know it was like it was a lesson in like how not to manage is what this was. So yeah, so after the Alberto project got shut down, pretty much everybody who was on the PowerPC team left in about six months. And that's when I went to Adobe and joined the Photoshop team. So the end result was a good thing for me. And so now fast forward, you know, we kind of talked about I'm at Adobe and I'm Macintosh tech lead on Photoshop.
我们在其中一条走廊里还有墓碑，每当有工程师离职，我们就画一块墓碑，把他们的名字刻在R.I.P.上。所以士气真的很高。嗯，当你说是精彩的演讲时，我以为会是那种振奋人心的，你知道的，这就好像是一堂关于如何不要进行管理的课，这就是这个演讲的全部内容。所以，是的，在Alberto项目被叫停后，PowerPC团队几乎所有人在大约六个月内都离职了。也就是在那时我去了Adobe并加入了Photoshop团队。所以最终结果对我来说是件好事。现在快进到，你知道的，我们刚才谈到我在Adobe，我是Photoshop的Macintosh技术主管。
And I come up with the Cyan proposal now that Steve Jobs is back at Apple and they're doing a transition that was going to be Rhapsody. And then there's the Cyan proposal, and then we find out about OS X when I get a call from Steve Jobs and get to go over to Apple and learn about OS X. And so all of that happens, and then I get a phone call from Phil Koch at Apple, and Phil says, hey, I'm leaving Apple, and I just wanted to come and have lunch with you. And I'm like, oh, that's great. And so he comes over, and we're sitting at lunch, and yeah, he said, I'm going to retire and leave Apple. He said, but I wanted to let you know something that you're probably not aware of.
现在史蒂夫·乔布斯回到了苹果，他们正在进行将成为Rhapsody的转型，我提出了Cyan提案。然后有了Cyan提案，接着当我接到史蒂夫·乔布斯的电话并去苹果了解OS X时，我们知道了OS X的事。所有这些都发生了，然后我接到了苹果菲尔·科赫的电话，菲尔说，嘿，我要离开苹果了，我只是想来跟你吃个午饭。我说，哦，太棒了。所以他过来了，我们坐在那里吃午饭，是的，他说，我要退休离开苹果了。他说，但我想让你知道一件事，你可能并不知道。
And he said, when this Cyan proposal happened, he said, this Apple executive who I won't name, but he's the person who had led to us cutting off negotiations around Rhapsody, who had written emails to John Warnock about both Greg Gilley and myself being impossible to work with. He said, yeah. So he said that at one point during that whole thing, the executive walked into my office and put a paper on my desk and said, I need you to write up why this won't work. And he said, I looked at the cover, he said, and it said, you know, the same proposal, Sean Parent. He said, and I handed it back and said it'll work and he said no he said the executive was like
他说，当这个Cyan提案出现时，他说，这位苹果高管我不会点名，但他就是导致我们切断关于Rhapsody的谈判的那个人，他曾写电子邮件给约翰·沃诺克（John Warnock），说格雷格·吉利（Greg Gilley）和我本人都无法共事。他说，是的。所以他说，在整个事件的某个时刻，这位高管走进了我的办公室，把一份文件放在我的桌子上，说，我需要你写一份报告，说明为什么这个行不通。他说，我看了看封面，他说，上面写着，你知道的，同样的提案，肖恩·帕伦特。他说，我把它还了回去，说它行得通。他说，不，他说这位高管说，
no that it wasn't a question of will it or won't it work I need a report from you that says it won't work and and Phil said I flat out refused he said I won't do that he said I'll tell you right now.
不，这不是行得通还是行不通的问题，我需要你出一份报告，说它行不通。菲尔说我断然拒绝了，他说我不会这么做，他说我现在就可以告诉你。
He said, I can read the paper and tell you why it will work, or you can just take my word for it. It's going to work. And handed it back. And he said, so. So he said, I, you know, he said, after what happened with PowerPC, he said, I thought you deserved to know that. So I thought that was an interesting side story. So that's what the story that Tony was, was referencing.
他说，我可以读这份文件并告诉你为什么它行得通，或者你可以相信我。它就是行得通。然后把文件还了回去。他说，所以。所以他说，我，你知道的，他说，在经历了PowerPC的事情之后，他说，我觉得你应该知道这一点。所以我觉得这是一个很有趣的幕后故事。这就是托尼提到的那个故事。
So the question is, is that the genesis of what ended up, you know, the start of the, what was it, two-year path to Steve Jobs then calling you back and like, hey, we'd like you to come over to Apple. Yeah, you know, if I had to guess, I think the timeframe there was probably just before the meeting where I blew up at this executive, right in between the meeting with Greg Gilley and the meeting that I had. Because I mentioned before that that meeting was supposed to be with Apple explaining the cost of them doing the Cyan proposal and kind of walking through the business aspects of this whole thing. And Apple just came in and said, you know, it's impossible and we're not doing it. And that's what led me to get into the argument about saying, you know, you're full of crap. And, you know, if, if, you know,
所以问题是，这就是最终导致，你知道的，史蒂夫·乔布斯后来给你打电话并说，嘿，我们希望你来苹果的那个历时两年的过程的起点吗？是的，你知道，如果我必须猜的话，那的时间框架可能刚好是在我和这位高管大吵一架的那次会议之前，就在与格雷格·吉利的会议和我自己开的会之间。因为我之前提到过，那次会议本该是苹果解释他们做Cyan提案的成本，并探讨这件事情的商业方面的会议。结果苹果一进来就说，你知道，这是不可能的，我们不打算做。这就导致我和他们争论起来，说，你知道的，你们在胡说八道。而且，如果，如果你想构建，你可以雇佣我，我去把它构建出来。对，对，对，百分之百是可行的。所以，所以我认为在那个会议之前，这位高管曾去找菲尔寻求弹药，而且，你觉得，我，我，我怀疑你是否能分享，你还留着那份报告的副本吗？你知道，不幸的是没有。
if you want to build, you can hire me and I'll go build it. Right. Right. It's, it's, it's a hundred percent doable. And so, so I think like before that meeting, uh, this executive had gone to Phil looking for ammunition and, uh, do you, I, I, I doubt that you'd be able to share it, but do you still have a copy of the report? You know unfortunately not
Cyan提案，我很乐意拥有它，就把它当成历史文物。我曾向苹果的一些朋友打听过，看有没有人保留着它，是的，我保留了很多旧电子邮件，但没有那么久以前的。我翻找过，在离开公司又回来之后，我找不到Cyan提案了。
the Cyan proposal I would love to have it just kind of as a historical artifact and I've kind of asked some friends at Apple to see if anybody kept it and yeah I keep a lot of old email, but like not anything that far back. And I kind of dug through and after, you know, leaving the company and coming back, I could not find the Cyan proposal.
所以，是的，如果你们的听众有谁随手留着旧副本的话。那会是哪一年呢？让我想想，我猜这应该是95年，所以如果你在1995年在苹果从事他们的操作系统工作，是的，如果你在Adobe工作，你可能也有一份副本，或者如果你在Adobe，我应该问问，我不知道我有没有问过拉塞尔·威廉姆斯（Russell Williams），他在苹果参与了将成为V1内核的工作，
So, yeah, if any of your listeners have an old copy lying about someplace. What year would it have been? So let's see this would have been i'm guessing 95 so if you worked at apple in 1995 on their operating system yeah you might have had a copy if you were working at uh at adobe too or if you're at adobe um I should ask I don't know that I've ever asked Russell Williams he worked on what was going to be the V1 kernel
后来我雇他在Photoshop工作，他从那以后就一直在Adobe从事Photoshop工作，是Photoshop团队的关键人物之一。Photoshop，他从那以后就一直在Adobe从事Photoshop工作，你知道，是Photoshop团队的关键人物之一。你还记得提案有多长吗？它只是一份白皮书，还是只有几页，或者像它只有几页，大约两页，很简短。你当时能分享它吗？我觉得这已经过去好几十年了，那会是的，是的，你知道，我甚至不认为它（特别有趣），你知道的，它基本上是我们计划对Alberto和V1做的事情的大纲，以及苹果最终在Mac OS X上用所谓的“蓝盒子”（blue box）所做的事情，但它基本上是说，是的，你可以拥有一个环境，在其中运行针对现有工具箱编写的现有应用程序。然后你还可以拥有一个环境，在这些环境中，应用程序可以调用基于Cocoa的新功能，并且你可以将两者混合搭配。从技术上讲，我不认为它有多么有趣，我不认为它有多么有趣，我不认为
at Apple and then I hired him to work on Photoshop and he's been at Adobe working on Photoshop ever since and one of the key people on the Photoshop team photoshop and he's been at adobe working on photoshop ever since and uh you know one of the key people on the photoshop team do you remember how long was the proposal was it just like a white paper was just a couple pages or was it like it was just a couple pages it was like two pages it was a short would you have been able to share it i feel like it's been
它就像是你知道的有趣，在混合模式领域，而且任何认真审视过这个问题的人都会想，哦，当然，你当然可以做到这一点，你知道，这只是苹果的勉强，苹果希望干净利落地转向NeXtStep并抛弃Mac的历史包袱。因此，当时Adobe和Microsoft的综合实力基本拒绝做出这种转变，这才是说服他们走向另一个方向的关键所在。而且，你知道，我听过来自苹果不同部门的人的各种说法，关于Cyan提案产生了多大影响，从毫无影响（你知道，无论如何都会发生），到如果没有它就不会发生，因为苹果对此坚决反对，并且没有明确的成功途径，除非有人写下来并承诺说，看，如果你这样做，我们会把Photoshop搬过去，对吧？
like a couple decades that that'd be yeah yeah you know i don't even think it was you know particularly interesting right it was it was uh uh uh you know basically it was an outline of what we had planned to do with uh with alberto and with v1 and so and what apple finally did with what was known as the blue box on Mac OS X, but it was basically saying that, yeah, you could have an environment where you could run existing apps that were written against the existing toolbox. And then you could also have an environment where those apps could call out to new Cocoa-based functionality, and you can mix and match the two. Technically, I don't think it was all that interesting. I don't think it was it was all that that interesting I don't think
所以这才是真正的推动力。而且，你知道，我们当时受到了苹果的大量指责，因为就像我说的，我们发现了这件事，两周后我们在舞台上做了一个演示，但这恰好发生在Photoshop开发周期的非常糟糕的时期，因为你知道我们当时在进行大约18个月的产品周期，我们刚刚完成一个版本的发布，所以我们在完成那个版本的发布时真的没有时间在其中加入对Mac OS X的支持。所以我们在蓝盒子中运行，这带来了一点性能损失，对吧？基本上，它是一个让你运行
it was like you know interesting and kind of the mixed mode space and I think anybody who seriously looked at the problem was like oh sure of course you could do that you know it was just Apple's reluctance Apple wanted kind of this clean move to to next step and to jettison the Mac baggage. And so it was much more the combined strength of, you know, Adobe and Microsoft at the time that basically refused to make that move that convinced them to go the other direction. And, you know, I've heard mixed reports from people in different parts of Apple as to how much of an impact the Cyan proposal had, anywhere from none, you know, it would have happened anyways, to it wouldn't have happened because Apple was so dead set against it and there wasn't any clear path in doing it to succeed, unless somebody wrote down and committed to say, look, we'll move Photoshop if you do this, right?
尚未移植的旧Mac应用程序的环境，持续了将近两年，对吧？直到我们发布所谓的“原生”Photoshop，将近两年时间过去了。而且，由于两台机器（蓝盒子内部和蓝盒子外部）都是PowerPC处理器，所以我们并没有遭遇重大的性能损失，但我们没有那种新颖诱人的UI外观，而且应用程序看起来过时了，是的，我记得，我敢打赌，我一生中唯一一次使用Mac是在那个时代，就在转换的那个时候，
And so that was the real impetus. And, you know, we got a lot of flack from Apple then, because, like I said, you know, we found out about this, and then two weeks later we gave a demo on stage, but it hit at a really bad time in the Photoshop development cycle because you know we were kind of running 18 month product cycles and we were just finishing up a release and so we didn't really have time in finishing up that release to do the the Mac OS X support in that. And so we ran in the blue box, which had a bit of a performance penalty, right? Basically, it was an environment that let you run
对，对，对，对，所以，你知道，我有点认为，那个时期以及Adobe和Microsoft施加压力的程度，为了让大家有个直观概念，你知道，在那个时期，Photoshop占了Mac上总软件收入的10%以上。不是Adobe的，只是总体而言。是的，不是Adobe总体的。在所有开发Mac软件的开发人员中，Photoshop占据了这块蛋糕的10%。但这改变了吗？因为我知道在那个时代甚至在那之后的10年里，
old Mac apps that hadn't been ported yet for almost two years, right? It was almost two years until we shipped a quote-unquote native Photoshop. And, you know, since both machines were, you know, both the blue box and outside the blue box were, you know, power PC processors, it wasn't like we were running some big performance penalty but we didn't have the the new kind of lickable looking ui and and the app look dated and yeah i remember i bet the one time in my life when i used uh max was around that era right around the switch
如果你在做那种创意工作，Mac就是你的首选平台。但近年来情况似乎有所改变。是的，好吧，是的，我仍然认为Mac在创意行业中更为普遍，但那部分市场对苹果来说已经不再那么重要了。甚至Mac对苹果来说也不再那么重要了，对吧？我的意思是，与现在的iOS销售额相比，它们简直相形见绌。是的，是的，我前几天看到一个有趣的图表，苹果AirPods的总业务量比许多知名科技公司的业务还要大。是的。包括，我想，甚至包括NVIDIA和Adobe，我敢肯定。
when yeah yeah yeah yep yep so you know i somewhat think that uh uh that time period and the amount of pressure that adobe and microsoft could exert right to put it in perspective you know at there was a period there where Photoshop accounted for more than 10% of the total software revenue on Mac. Not Adobe's, just in general. Yeah, not of Adobe's general. Of all developers that were developing Mac software, Photoshop was taking a 10% cut of that pie. But has that changed? Because I know back during that era and even for like 10 years after that,
哦，是的。是的。而且，我有点认为App Store的规则就是为了确保没有任何公司占据主导地位而设计的。有趣。对吧。为什么苹果不希望这样呢？是的。
Macs were the platform that you'd go to if you were doing that sort of creative work. But it seems like it's changed a bit in recent years. Yeah, yeah. Well, yeah, I still think Macs tend to be more prevalent in kind of the creative
因为占据主导地位的公司可以对苹果施加控制。对，对。他们不想和世上的肖恩·帕伦特打交道。他们不想和我打交道。这就是全部原因。有趣。苹果不想和肖恩打交道，这就是全部原因，这很有趣。苹果不想和肖恩打交道，这就是为什么你们所有人必须忍受App Store。你可以把这个放进播客里，这很有意思。好吧，那就是所谓的推特上的争执还是别的什么，某家公司跳出来说他们违反了规则并挑起这场争端，因为那是Epic，对吧？嗯，是的，因为我想，是的，一旦发生这种情况，
industry, but that segment of the market isn't as important for Apple anymore. Even Macs aren't as important for Apple anymore, right? I mean, they're completely dwarfed by iOS sales at this point yeah yeah i saw i saw this funny graphic the other day that um like the the apple's total business for airpods is like larger than the than the business of like a number of notable tech companies. Yep. Including, I think, both NVIDIA and Adobe, I'm sure.
那么就像你说的，他们可以开始对话或迫使对方就范，说“我们不付这30%的费用”。是的，周围还在发生诉讼吗？我听说基本上他们说他们现在不付了。现在Epic诉苹果案以及该诉讼中的证据发现简直太滑稽了。在证据发现期间披露的文件简直是非常滑稽，因为它们碰巧顺便泄露了一堆其他公司正在进行的秘密项目和计划。嗯，所以你会，会有从这起诉讼中衍生出来的诉讼，可能不会，但是，是的，这很有趣，我一直在读有关它的新闻，
Oh, yeah. Yeah. And, you know, I somewhat think the App Store rules are structured around trying to make sure that you don't have any companies that dominate. Interesting. Right. Why is that something that Apple wouldn't want? Yeah.
而且我在推特上关注了蒂姆·斯威尼（Tim Sweeney）。哦，是的，几个月前他说了一些关于C++的不太好听的话，因为我记得在CppCast上他们说，哦，也许我们应该请蒂姆·斯威尼来，然后就像快进三周后，我看到蒂姆·斯威尼说C++是，我不知道。我不记得他说过什么了，但不好听。肖恩，你觉得这类事情会怎样发展？你认为像Epic这样的应用开发者最终会成功重新获得对生态系统的一些控制权吗？嗯，我认为有趣的是，现在微软处于这样一种地位：他们不再占据主导地位，而且他们是一个饥饿的玩家，仍然拥有可观的市场份额。你知道，就台式电脑而言，你知道，他们有一个问题，即他们从未成功过渡到移动领域，但如果你看看，他们宣布了（随着Windows 11的推出）对他们的App Store非常合理的条款，基本上就是
Because a company that dominates can exert control on Apple. Right, right. They don't want to have to deal with the Sean parents of the world. They don't want to have to deal with me. That's the whole thing. Interesting. Apple doesn't want to have to deal with me that's the whole thing it's interesting apple doesn't want to deal with sean that's why you guys all have to live with the app store you can put that in the podcast that makes a lot of well that's sort of the what was the twitter beef or whatever some company was it that they came out that they were breaking the rules and starting this feud because it was epic yeah um yeah yeah because i guess yeah as soon as that
你知道的，你把东西放到App Store里，如果他们处理金融交易，他们就会抽成，大约是5%的抽成，你知道的，这更符合你对一些联合营销和信用卡费用的预期，基本上就是为你处理金融交易。他们甚至说过，如果他们不处理金融交易，他们就不会抽成。所以我认为这会稍微改变动态。你知道，苹果现在太大了，我不知道这能给他们施加多少压力。
happens then like you said they can sort of start a conversation or force their hand and be like we're not paying this 30 fee yeah is there still like a loss lawsuits happening around that i heard that's basically they they said that they weren't going to pay now the epic versus apple lawsuit and the discovery the discoveries in that lawsuit has just been hilarious the the the documents that were that were revealed during discovery have just been uh very hilarious because they've happened to incidentally reveal a bunch of like secret projects and plans that other companies were undertaking um yeah so you're gonna be there's gonna be lawsuits branching off of this lawsuit probably not but uh but yeah it's it's interesting i've been i've been reading the news about it a little bit
但我认为这会带来...我认为这肯定对微软生态系统以及扩大微软商店的供应大有裨益。而且拥有一个集中的商店，知道你的软件是最新的，并且至少有人在审查它以确保它经过认证，这感觉很好，对吧？你知道，你在网上买Adobe的产品或主要产品时会感到自信，但很多时候，如果是个小工具什么的，你会想：我真的想从这个自90年代以来就没有更新过的、看起来可疑的网站下载吗？或者商店里也许有能用的东西，至少我知道我安装在机器上运行的东西有一个把关的因素。所以，是的，所以，所以我认为微软可能会成功开始改变这种动态，而且我认为如果Google想要进一步区分Android空间
and i follow tim sweeney on the on twitter yeah oh yeah he said some unkind things about c++ a couple months ago uh because i remember on cpp cast they were like oh maybe we should get tim sweeney on and then like fast forward three weeks i see tim sweeneyey saying that C++ is, I don't know. I can't remember what he said, but it wasn't nice. What do you think will happen with this sort of stuff, Sean? Do you think that the app developers like Epic will eventually prevail in regaining some control of the ecosystem? Well, I think the interesting thing is now Microsoft is in a position where they're no longer dominant and they're the hungry player with still significant market share. You know, as far as desktop computers go, you know, they have a problem that they never made a successful transition to the mobile space but if you look they announced you know with Windows 11 very reasonable terms for their App Store which is basically
与iOS空间，并效仿微软的做法，对Google来说这是一个机会。在Google的情况下，我认为这是合理的，因为我确信他们赚了很多钱，但他们从Android App Store赚到的不是苹果规模的钱。但是，你知道的，而且他们在平台上赚钱的大部分收入是广告收入。那是他们的主要业务。所以我认为他们或许可以通过实际降低成本结构来改善他们的平台，从而给自己带来净收益。至于他们是否会这么做，我没有内幕消息。
you know you put things in the App Store and if they handle the financial transaction then they take a cut which is like a 5% cut which is you know more in line with what you would expect for kind of a little co-marketing and a and you know a credit card fee basically, for running the financial transaction for you. And they've even said if they don't handle the financial transaction, then they won't take their cut. And so I think that's going to change the dynamics a bit. You know, Apple is so big at this point, I don't know how much pressure that puts on them.
这里100%纯属猜测。但再次强调，这可能会开始给苹果施加竞争压力，迫使其屈服。或者像Epic这样的人可能会在这个领域赢得一场诉讼并将其打开。或者，你知道的，维修权的支持者可能会赢得一些诉讼并确立更好的维修权。这与此相关。对于科技领域的这些法律问题来说，这当然是一个有趣的时刻，因为现在有一堆这样的案件正处于白热化阶段。是的。还会有另一个大规模的案件，即将爆出的暴雪事件。现在情况挺糟糕的。是的。还会有另一个大规模的案件。
But I think it will make a... I think it will certainly be good for the Microsoft ecosystem and for kind of expanding the Microsoft store offerings. And there is something nice about having kind of a centralized store and knowing that your software is up to date and that at least somebody is looking at it to make sure it's certified, right? You know, you feel confident like buying an Adobe product
即将爆出的暴雪事件。情况挺糟糕的。暴雪听起来不像是工作的好地方。听起来不像是工作的好地方。是的。把你的简历发给Adobe吧。我们是个工作的好地方。
or a major product over the web, but a lot of times if it's a little utility or something, I'll see you be like, do I want to download this from this sketchy looking website that hasn't been updated since the 90s? Or maybe there's something that will work that's in the store where I at least know, you know, there's a little bit of a gating factor into what I'm installing and running on my machine. So, so, yeah, so, so, so I think, you know, Microsoft might successfully start to change the dynamics and I think there's an opportunity for Google there if Google wants to more differentiate the Android space
或者通过网络购买主要产品，但很多时候如果是小工具之类的，我会想：我真的要从这个看起来从90年代以后就没有更新过的可疑网站下载吗？或者应用商店里有没有能用的替代品，至少我知道我安装和运行在机器上的东西是有一定审核门槛的。所以，我觉得微软可能会成功改变这种动态，而且如果谷歌想进一步区分Android和iOS空间，以效仿微软的做法，对谷歌来说这也是个机会。
from the iOS space to kind of follow suit with what Microsoft is doing. And in the case of Google, I think that's a reasonable thing because I'm sure they make a lot of money, but they don't make Apple-sized money out of the Android App Store. But they, you know, and most of their money generating on the platform is advertising revenue. That's their main business. And so I think that they might be able to improve their platform to net benefit for them by actually reducing their cost structure. Whether or not they'll do it, I have no insight.
就谷歌而言，我认为这是合理的，因为我确信他们能赚很多钱，但他们从Android应用商店赚到的钱远不及苹果的规模。不过他们在该平台上主要靠广告收入赚钱。那是他们的主营业务。因此，我认为他们可能会通过降低成本结构来改善其平台，从而为自己带来净收益。至于他们会不会这么做，我不得而知。
100% pure conjecture here. But that, again, might start to put competitive pressure on Apple to cave. Or somebody like Epic might just win a lawsuit in this space and open it up. Or, you know, the right to repair folks might win some lawsuits and establish a better right to repair. It's related. Certainly an interesting time for these legal issues in tech because there's a bunch of these cases coming to a head right now. Yeah. There's going to be another massive one, the Blizzard stuff that's coming out. It's pretty now. Yeah. There's going to be another massive one.
这完全是我的纯粹猜测。但这又可能会对苹果施加竞争压力，迫使其妥协。或者像Epic这样的公司可能会在这个领域赢得诉讼并将其开放。或者，你知道的，维修权倡导者可能会赢得一些诉讼并确立更好的维修权。这与此相关。对科技领域的这些法律问题来说，这绝对是一个有趣的时期，因为现在有一堆这样的案件正在进入白热化阶段。是的。还会有另一个重磅案件，也就是暴雪爆出的那些事。现在看来挺糟糕的。是的。还会有另一个重磅案件。
The Blizzard stuff that's coming out. It's pretty awful. Blizzard does not sound like a nice place to work. It does not sound like a nice place to work. Yep. Send your resumes to Adobe. We're a nice place to work.
暴雪爆出的那些事。这挺糟糕的。暴雪听起来可不是个好工作场所。听起来真不是个好工作场所。没错。把你们的简历投给Adobe吧。我们是个好工作场所。
Yeah, let's think of the software technology lab as a restart. It's an exciting time we're a nice place yeah let's think of the the st the software technology lab is uh has restarted and that's gonna be an exciting and it's an exciting time to to go go work at adobe i bet it is it is and uh uh yeah and i think you know adobe if you look you know consistently ranks in the in the in the list for for one if not the top places to work. And I think kind of the way we've been managing the pandemic and now kind of getting people starting to migrate back to work
是的，我们可以把软件技术实验室看作是一个全新的开始。这是一个令人兴奋的时刻，我们是一个很棒的地方。是的，我们可以把软件技术实验室看作是重新启动了，这将是一个令人兴奋的时刻，在Adobe工作肯定很棒。确实如此，而且我认为，如果你看一下Adobe，就会发现它一直在各种最佳工作场所排行榜上名列前茅。我认为我们在应对疫情的方式上，以及现在开始让人们逐渐回归工作岗位的过程中，
and the amount of flexibility the company has shown in that space, I think has been very good and enlightening. And the company has been listening to their employees and trying to be very flexible. Not insisting that everybody go back to the office like Apple and Google. The company has been listening to their employees and trying to be very flexible. Not insisting that everybody go back to the office like Apple and Google. Yes, not insisting that everybody goes back to the office. The company has basically come out and said,
公司在这一领域展现出的灵活性非常好，也很有启发意义。公司一直在倾听员工的心声，并努力保持高度的灵活。不像苹果和谷歌那样坚持要求每个人都回到办公室。公司一直在倾听员工的心声，并努力保持高度的灵活。不像苹果和谷歌那样坚持要求每个人都回到办公室。是的，不坚持要求每个人都回办公室。公司基本上已经表态，
we're going to have flexible time as the default for people. I didn't know that Apple, I heard that Facebook and Twitter both decided like a year ago, they were like, oh, this seems to work fine. Feel free to stay forever working remotely. But Apple and Google both are mandating people have to come back? At least somewhat, yeah. Yeah, at least somewhat.
我们将把弹性工作制作为员工的默认选择。我不知道苹果……我听说Facebook和Twitter在一年前就决定了，它们当时觉得，哦，这似乎运作得很好。大家可以永远远程办公。但是苹果和谷歌都强制要求人们回办公室吗？至少在某种程度上是的。是的，至少在某种程度上。
They're coming up with different terms. I haven't been following all the news in and out, but I was reading something this morning where basically I think the gist of it was that Apple's policy was either you register as a remote worker, you know, or you come into the office on a full time. And if you're a remote worker, it means you're not in the office on a regular basis.
他们提出了不同的条款。我没有一直关注所有的相关新闻，但我今天早上读到的一篇报道的大意基本上是，苹果的政策要么是你注册为远程工作者，要么就是全职去办公室。如果你是一名远程工作者，那就意味着你不会定期去办公室。
And that comes with, you know, ramifications for pay and benefits and things of that nature. Some of that is unavoidable, right? Some of it is just kind of baked into tax laws and employment laws and things like that. But Adobe is basically dividing it into you can be a remote worker or you can be a flex worker. And a flex worker is everything from in the office all the time to just in the office on some regularly scheduled pattern.
这会带来薪酬、福利等方面的相应影响。其中一些是不可避免的，对吧？有些本来就受税法、劳动法等法律法规的制约。但Adobe基本上将其划分为你可以成为远程工作者，或者你可以成为弹性工作者。弹性工作者包括从全职在办公室到按固定时间表去办公室的各种情况。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢本期节目，祝你有美好的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。